this podcast is where facts come to die
yep
they're gonna come we don't know them we
don't know the facts we know what we
think we might have heard
well i know i read a thing that said
[Music]
wow okay i had to uh this is a side note
but i had to
learn how to breathe again again again
um breathe you don't breathe like
diaphragmatic breathing yeah
i go to a uh rolfer
thing yeah rofl that's a type of
like body adjustment and the guy
base was like yo you're a belly breather
huh i was like yeah he's like no
i'm like i stop i started doing this
because somebody else told me i was
breathing wrong
it's suppose it's the opposite it's like
when you breathe in
it's supposed it's basically however
babies breathe is how you're doing it
it's like when you go but i don't think
that's
i think babies are belly breathers when
you breathe in it's supposed to go out
right but i was doing that and that's
wrong according to this guy
so so i wore a girdle two days this week
don't worry about it
oh yeah it was actually a band yeah
basically i did that i
called up khloe kardashian and she sent
me a little mark
um we got a song that we got to start
the show off with
because this guy who sent it christopher
bill christopher bill
christopher bill can you believe it
um so christopher bill
sent in a sitcom
version of how neal feel and it's about
as glorious a song as we've ever gone
okay we'll go
[Music]
and he did the short one like he did a
good just starting you did a
part that's a perfect pair it's just
missing like shana nana
nah it's the different no i mean just
it's good
it's fantastic it's a dip that there was
a guy who used to do
theme songs like that i don't know what
that that's obviously the the full house
parody
but that guy had three or four on the
market on the streets
family matters and full house yeah
friday night friday what was it called
uh a tj have dude friday
i'm old so i didn't catch any of them uh
they were just
i was working on those shows oh okay um
uh will still haven't made a good edit
on that
um but i don't know
um anyhow
so i learned how to breathe you're
killing me
um i went to a rolfer
i spent it just feels like you've
already made up the first two things you
did
i i did a lot of bed boying i had to
rewrite some stuff
this week so i was just in bed
bad boy um and i did
comedy at the comedy store
and the improv and
an outdoor show in l.a outdoor are they
hitting still
yeah i don't know how much longer
they're gonna be able to do them but
there is something
if you pay they pay if the store pays 50
and those outdoor shows paid 250.
i'm not going to say no to an outdoor
show um
damn i didn't know so we're paying yeah
they're paying because they're they're
charging a lot
yeah and and they don't
have like we have overhead right they
just it's they just
four wallet as they call it in the biz
um
kind of bombed both times with the
improv
weirdly enough which they improv the
outdoor improv
no the improv indoor improv store i've
been doing great but
the improv i vary on what they call
uneven sets
where i don't know what i didn't know
what jokes were gonna work
i was like i have no id one joke would
work
and then and like and then the next one
oh
but it was the same amount of [ __ ]
transgressive so it was impossible to
follow
does the the did those situations throw
you off
yes you know why it's not enjoyable
going into a joke
when you don't know what's going to
happen if you think it'll probably work
you could tell it better yeah but if you
tell someone a story and they're like
then
maybe i'm not going to tell this person
so many stories or
and then you cut it short you don't do
as many tags yeah
or do i do like hits
which do mean no good whatsoever you're
also
very good when you bomb so was it not
that good that goodness i had a good
bomb
and i had a bad bomb oh no i had a good
bomb where
i was like making fun of it yeah yeah
and it's very funny when neil's bombing
yeah it was you know
it was pretty funny um and
the bad bomb i had a little
a thing hap i'm not on zoloft anymore
yeah
there are points now and it happened
before like years ago
little panic attacks oh i remember you
told me you had one as you were going on
stage
yes and and at the improv on friday i
hadn't been on the stage in a long time
that stage in particular
and i got a little i got a panic attack
in the first
it's just a surge what does it feel like
just can't breathe
can't think think everyone can tell
and they can tell i can't really speak
so it is that's a problem that's a big
problem when you're speaking when you're
there to speak
uh so it takes probably eight seconds i
think i have a
thing i can i realize the kinds of jokes
i can do when i'm in that
you should do hits to get you out i just
have to do jokes with short sentences
if that makes sense like easy logic to
remember
and short sentences how long until
you're like okay i'm back
uh 25 seconds okay so i was thinking of
like
a joke going like uh you guys might have
a panic attack real quick
that's really funny and uh round of
applause who wants to see me have a man
i have a few ideas uh but um
it's a not no i'm not i don't like it
i'll say well yeah i don't it doesn't
sound comfortable at all
uh is that because you haven't done aya
in a second or no
it's because i haven't it's happened
on stages that i haven't been on either
never been on
or haven't been on an award going back
yeah you're not going to go back on solo
because you can't do it no i also don't
need it other than
panicking at my job okay okay um a
little bump little bro
but yeah like a little that's i don't
know that's kind of scary
yeah i don't know what panic i mean i've
had panic attacks but only
very situational like i'm very
claustrophobic so when i'm in elevator i
have a panic attack
almost every time what do you do
i mean i can't do much because i'm
already in the elevator but i
i just like face the corner
so if you see me in the elevator and i
leave her leave her be
guys if you see her in the elevator in
the corner and the problem is that if
someone comes in the elevator's like you
know people who just are annoying button
pushers
i i have i can't control like stop
please
stop and they think you're talking to
the wall you're not facing them no i'm
turning around
oh you do try to remember that just be
like does that make the panic worse
the button pushing i'm like what the
[ __ ] it's gonna close
you you push yeah there was a long new
york article about
at elevators
or whoever makes there's one company
that makes like 90 otis sorry
otis makes uh schlage makes lots
of drinks um otis
make 90 90 85 or something and uh 85
percent of elevators they make and
so it was just a long article about the
company and how they
developed it forwarded to new york look
it up new yorker
new yorker okay yeah uh the funny thing
is in my building
the elevators from the 60s and so it's
the
it's a manual accordion one
yeah you know that you have to close by
wow and i don't get scared in those
which everybody else is frightened in
that one because it's like shaking and
rigging
it's because i can breathe i can see the
outside yeah
you you are comforted by the thing that
freaks everybody out
exactly uh you can see rats there's my
guy
as you're going past them the humble
elevator and the rise of modern
civilization
typical new york article like even the
title it's like
it says it all right yep the um anyhow
so you rolfed yeah i did a lot of stand
up i bed-boyed it
ew of course what's going on ooh i don't
know i just don't see it as like a
cause i think you're you're like the
anti-rich guy
you don't do rich guy stuff it's not a
public court it's not like
it's not like like like in my backyard
no i know but you just don't do typical
rich guy stuff so when you do i'm like
yeah it doesn't feel like it doesn't
it's public court so it's i guess it's
you know what i'm saying this is why
stereotypes don't work
the best tennis player in the world is a
black woman so
it's like why didn't that it's the
joke i never do which is that only
negative stereotypes take off
they don't no one ever after obama no
one said you know how these black people
are
building consensus and right and super
logical well no i mean the problem is
like to me
golfing's still a white sport even
though tiger woods is like one of the
greats
the funny thing about tennis i i you're
absolutely right the funny thing about
tennis is
i think michael costa did a joke about
this what
it's the language all that 40 love you
know it's hard to follow
right intentional to keep poor people
away
damn really intentional it's like a way
what are white people doing i mean wow
wow
wow was that the cold open of wimbledon
yes now
or was that a hot drop from will
um so
so yeah so tennis enjoyable okay and
rolfing of course who can forget and
then just stand up how about you
i have an answer i love it i
went and visited my me madre did it
really yeah i went to the bay
how long had it been i once
how long had it been probably like four
months from christmas
it's a long time for you yeah kind it
feels so close though like i just live
in far away places so this doesn't feel
that bad like i don't complain about it
as much because i can
if i really want i can go after the pod
and go
you know i'll be there in like five
hours but um it was so funny so i
stopped at like
a place to get a breakfast burrito
because i rented a car
and there was a guy just brushing his
hair in the parking lot
standing outside the breakfast spot and
he was staring at me i was like
god okay so i go and i order my
breakfast burrito
and he comes and he's like so you blow
it out
and i'm like i'm sorry it's like you
blow that thing out
you blew it out just straighten it and
like
oh my hair and he's like yeah i'm like
yeah i've blown it out and straightened
it how long does it take you
i'm like he had longest hair no he did
[ __ ] like he looked like your hair
i don't know i was brushing it uh and
then he's like
as an icebreaker that's why i'll tell
you why
i was like um an hour
that's how long it would take me to do
it to blow your hair out yes
and i was like oh okay oh he's like
i did hair for 25 years like start with
that that was so weird
yeah it was very it was such a weird
exchange and then he was like
my favorite hair texture you have my
favorite hair texture
i was just like this guy
burnout yeah he was like i did here for
25 years and i retired and now i sell
weed
i was like okay okay i'm gonna go now
bye don't murder me um and then i
finally made it after that
frightening interaction i made it to the
bay and it was lovely
visited me madre and friends and it was
like 85 degrees in san francisco
yeah i don't know who'd have talked
about this [ __ ] l.a weather
yeah it was i left the entire time i
i mean i'm from guys it's 63. i'm from
the south all the time
so it's better weather san francisco 85
with a breeze so it brought it down to
like 80.
lovely no clouds the whole time was in
the bay i come here
what'd you do neil you're paying too
much tennis garbage you're upset
it's been garbage for three months uh is
this
may good uh this i don't know if this is
i don't know if this is climate change i
like it
okay
the seasons are gonna no it's gonna
change the jet stream
so [ __ ] like london's gonna be freezing
london's very far north london's north
of america
so it's going to be more that climate
they're like
surviving now on a they got a hot they
got a good jet stream
and uh what are we gonna do
america is just gonna move my prediction
is a law i'll be long dead
i'll be in the beam vancouver will be
los angeles meaning what in what terms
uh
way better like la weather and what's
going on with us
oh this is on fire oh it'll still be
warm
yeah but it'll be on literally it'll be
on on fire
and you won't be able to get water so
get your stuff cool
pack your stuff start packing now by the
end of the podcast
what will happen with your loft what
will be of your legacy
well there's a climate there's a ocean
rising
issue that i've thought about i mean
most of real estate is like
tricking people into buying your [ __ ]
like hey yo dog and then someone tricks
me into buying their it's just
trickery it's it's levels of trickery
in college uh we like in california you
have to go
on a field trip if you take geology
geography geography
and so all we did was go to the beach
and my teacher just pointed to
everybody's beachfront property and said
like
where the foundational issues are and
the issues they're gonna have like
coming
just due to erosion and he was just like
do not buy property
near the beach yeah everything will
always end up in the ocean
yeah but every once in a while in miami
it's like bring your [ __ ] water wings
because you're gonna need that
sweetheart
um so anyhow
you seen facebook not in a while
yes um it's the they
they prolong the trial this this
i don't have a lot of sympathy for these
for really anyone i know um corporations
are pretty low down as well
they're below people people are already
pretty low um
if you're facebook
what do you do because the thing that
the
facebook's in a position where if donald
trump does a press conference cnn canara
fox can eric everyone can air it and he
donald trump can lie during the during
the speech or the stump speech or the
press conference
and they don't they just go that's what
he says
if he posts it on facebook then it
becomes like this weaponized thing
so if you're facebook you got to be like
well what also he's the president
you don't think the president should be
heard
but they banned him after he was right
of course yeah but i'm saying
it's it's uh you think he's still in the
presidency it's like newsworthiness
that's like the that's the category he
is
gaming the system they didn't no one
imagined
a president this corrupt he's gaming the
system but
i they're in a [ __ ] really hard
position
yeah for sure also because like
it was so much nonsense
where i don't know there's no what's
like where do they just be like all
right [ __ ] because i also facebook isn't
like holding everyone to task
for not knowing well they say inciting
violence
and that's one of those things trump's
really good at never saying
he's very good at never never saying the
thing to get him prosecuted
it's kind of his b his gift yeah is
getting
incredibly close to the line and that's
what america allows for it allows for
incendiary speech right up yeah
technicalities like
right up to you getting punched in the
face what was what did he say
and he added something and he's like he
added something
to a speech he gave and then
some i don't know enough to basically
this they
they were prevented from suing him
because he said
he just added like one word of like
sometimes
yeah not really or like you know
you know what i mean folks just some
something that like neutralizes
everything that no one cares about but
technically and legally
gets him out of it yeah he's been
speaking publicly for a long time
sad that facebook is the has to be the
pillar of morality here
well that's what happens when you when
you
build a it's the rogan issue it's the
it's the same
issue people have with rogan they didn't
they have a billion users
or two billion something like i don't
know what the
what the numbers are i think it's
uh
in a million two and a half billion so
they have
sorry 2.7 billion so almost three
billion that's almost everybody
right because once you subtract babies
and [ __ ] it's like you it's a [ __ ]
almost everybody
right um and then you become
it's the john stewart thing it's a rogan
thing it's like well now
we were just kind of funny right
and now it's now
now we're a news organization and a
religious organization and all these
other organizations that they didn't
that [ __ ] asperger's case can't it's
not
in his his wheelhouse is
numbers right so then it's like make a
moral decision he goes
i'm in favor of holocaust deniers being
on facebook i wouldn't stop them and
then six months later he's like
i thought about the holocaust deniers
thing and i'm against it now
wow man what happened did you hear about
the [ __ ] holland like
so i wouldn't want to
i don't envy them no i don't do that
it's a
awful position and then they have to
grow quarter to quarter
and they their bottom line is making
money
but now they have a morality issue and
then it would just be easier if they
could
like it's i think for like 24-hour news
cycle networks they have
certain rules they have to buy to and
they don't have to
and it's just easy for them because it's
like well they used to
they've deregulated them they've
deregulated them but they still like
have
one new show at like four a.m like they
do all the things right the africa show
yeah
that's always on cnn international i
actually love it i love it
i love watching it at home because it
makes me feel like i'm on vacation
because in when you're in a foreign
country good luck finding anything on
cnn except for cnn
africa spotlight on africa or something
uh
yeah highlights every story is about um
it's great
it's about trevor or uh who's not t
pain the other one uh a con
every story's about eight counter
totally um
finding water yes um yeah it's weird
that now we have to
look to facebook to solve issues that no
one wants to deal with no no one i don't
want to deal with it and i'm the biggest
know what all
most people have ever met yeah um but
and i'm like i don't [ __ ] know yeah i
have no [ __ ] idea it's another one of
my controversial opinions
i don't know i don't i don't know what
to do
thank you um we gotta figure out
the syndications the guy sent in the
song to go with syndicated stories
because it's like it sounds like a
syndicated sitcom yeah so we got to
figure out a shorter version well well
will you do a horrible edit on that
please
real honey just ding ding ding that's it
um
guys do you see will's process and see
how infuriating it is
um well it's like do you remember that
seinfeld where uh somebody suggested
jerry's like i got a great contractor
he's like oh he's great but
he just ends up asking like way too many
questions and he's like
i don't care do whatever don't ask me
another [ __ ] question and
do you remember that uh i've never
watched time you've never watched live
i watched like four of them you're
friends with seinfeld i said it on the
tv show on the comedians and cars why
not uh because i don't like sit comps
you don't like sycamores no
he said he goes i didn't like him either
i was like you would like
the funniest thing the most seinfeld
character thing you can do
is not watch seinfeld no one on seinfeld
would watch science no way like they'd
be like
kramer wouldn't have time no george
would be like stupid
right uh elaine would be like i don't
have time like they'd all have reasons
why
jerry's like i don't like watching
comedians um
now facebook you saw the facebook apple
thing we didn't even put on the
on the sheet so there's a the new ios
you can this doesn't pertain to you you
can be tracked or not you can opt out of
tracking
every any website on your phone any app
you can opt out of tracking do not track
me once i leave this app
which they all do which that's how these
websites make money um
apple just introduces where you can
opt out of any any app any website
any website from any country because
it's very hard when you go to
london i went to one i'm like no [ __ ]
this i'm going to opt out of everything
oh my god it was like
safari is a bit of a pain where it's
like what kind of cookies yeah we always
allow
sometimes allow it's confusing how about
fridays
what are you doing next week and you're
like i don't want to be followed ever
but they're like we need helps us
so you can so facebook's
96 of people said do not track me
on on ios do you what do you use apple
maps
or do you use no use google go into it
so it's setting
go into they have tr i've stumbled upon
it they
track everywhere everywhere i've ever
been since 2005.
yeah i was gonna look and um
when we try to figure out what we did
this week i'm like i don't know
let me look at my map oh no i was like
that is so
everywhere i've ever been since 2005.
conference man
really someone cares weird well no but
that's
four i like the four percent of people
that were like you know what i do want
facebook
keep keep your eye on me who knows what
i'm going to be doing
uh so facebook rest in power king
um or something the best of i mean just
yeah like really figure it out best of
luck
tough break you created a monster
tough break it's ted turner one time
said
you're not truly successful in american
business until the government intervenes
which is like yep well i got good news
bad news facebook
you're really successful bad news is
this guy's from the government
um now i didn't know about this you told
me about something called fox mania
right so it's a defense
that one of the uh one of the people
that
um during the interaction on january 6th
one of them that's being prosecuted or
charged their lawyer is using
they came up with a thing called fox
mania or foxitis
to as a defense foxitis is when black
people watch fox and they fall asleep
20 minutes later right go ahead keep
going uh
and it's basically like political
hysteria he
so it said he lost his job during the
pandemic and just had
fox news on morning noon and night and
became
kind of tired
and uh then he became convinced of
every single every single thing they
said
and that's that's his defense for why he
stormed the gap
they didn't say storm the capital did
they say that on the air
who fox meaning he's like i did
everything he said they didn't say storm
the capital
no i mean i here's the thing that's why
but that's the thing
it's never where do they get this idea
i'm
i'm uh interviewing you spell itis with
a u
fox fox [ __ ] like some [ __ ] he made
it oh
gladiator [ __ ] um
fox itis i have msnbc
cut my hair like rachel maddow and got
the glasses so right there
i'm all ready as you can see
i'm already a quasi-lesbian
just off the jump um
my obvious is hilarious right
it would also be really funny to do a
bunch of them like b
titus right i was like what what
cnn is you just you you what
you you are
you can't believe the people you're
interviewing you're like i don't know
why i'm interviewing this person that's
a [ __ ] but i i'm gonna try to be
even-handed about it because why not
uh here where's rick santorum can we get
him on here
um if
this part of me is like i i
don't mind giving these people
an out meaning
i'd like them to if we're talking about
rehabilitation right
if you're willing it's like if you have
foxitis
we'll block it if you like just to get
out of that
infosphere um if you really if it's
making you
cause do crime right then we'll just
get get it out of your life but you have
seriously but you also have to penalize
fox
um this is a this is another this is the
facebook issue
this is the favorite mayor like foot
mayor yes which is
people no longer
all all of
any uh speaking
is biased yeah so
every news organization is going to be
biased
fox can argue that this is just
their take right on things
and you'd be hard-pressed to disprove
them
do you know what i mean like you'd be
hard-pressed to go like that's not what
you think
you think this and you're doing this did
it it's like proving liable right it's
very hard to do yeah so it's
atrocious what they do it's atrocious
it's and it's very
obvious yes and it's like no well and
they're technically not doing anything
illegal
you know it's like i know these are all
opinions i'm just kidding
you stop hitting yourself right it's
like that [ __ ] so i'm like
okay if we're let's let's go with it
if we're gonna say that is it's almost
like pleading insanity
like i got the fox ice yeah then you got
to get locked up in a place
in the ins in the sanitarium
for fox itis which is i'll see you in
there
uh the
yeah there's no that that the dominion
is gonna
they're suing all women that could be
great that's gonna be
edge is so funny like know what plot
twist of the whole story
is demeanings like oh no no you know
here they just act like a [ __ ]
dominion did it like the scapegoat
it's like i'm not an actual goat i can
hire a legal team and make a lot and we
know you guys have a lot of [ __ ]
money right
um i hope they they'll probably settle
but it'll be for a lot of money
it'll be for a little bit um they should
i mean there should be like some kind of
takeover where dominion can take over
the airways for
a week so
great uh is this is the people returning
pets would that be for um
did you see this our new segment did you
see this no no
the do you have a show and i have it i
have it is it on the sheet or is it not
so
oh off the dome off the table all right
so this is not
a this is uh people returning pets
so apparently after thinking about so
after the um
after the pandemic now because so many
people got pets
during the pandemic to keep them company
so now
kennels and all these people are seeing
a huge rise in people dropping their
pets off
because they're they're no longer needed
and it's thank you pets for yourself
it's like it's so [ __ ] up
um what's wrong with people yeah
shelters are seeing higher than average
returns
same shelters saw spike in adoptions
people face lockdowns
are we that like um predictable and
uh transactional it's just a transaction
i don't need you anymore
thank you thanks
it's just a disposable society it's like
[ __ ] uh
iphone 12 like uh uh
i don't even want to touch it i
literally
makes me vomit
somebody got interviewed and he's like
well things are opening up and i'm like
i don't have as much time
yeah all the reasons were sure yeah but
yeah what did he think they do people
did people think they were gonna return
them like probably
no not no but i think once things got up
i just there's okay that my only defense
would be
all right would be
if you can't if you're not home
and you can't afford a dog walker and
it's like well what do i do
i this dog is gonna tear my house up be
miserable i get it i just
why are people so it's just
it's grossly predictable yeah oh no i'm
going out now
hot girl summer it's the here's the sad
thing
the the uh whatever the worst thing you
can
predict is gonna happen yeah it's
generally what's gonna happen
okay it like no okay then let's let's
make some predictions let's see do you
what do you think so do you think that
do you think corona is going to
surge again surge in america
no okay
give me a number over how many a day
do you think it's gonna go back to 300
000 a day
i don't think that'll ever happen again
personally i now
there's a big caveat which is let's see
how long these vaccines last
we're down to like 38 39 000 a day now
the average is 41 which is great yeah um
look i want to see those hospital
numbers come down yeah
they're around 37 000 you know every
night we can do better guys
look at these numbers also getting
bigger on the east coast going on there
uh that's being ruled out isn't it there
it's what happens is certain states
um you don't think will ever be it'll be
like i don't think we're gonna get to
300 000. you don't think it'll ever be
india
um we a guy
followed me on twitter comedian and
he i he's indian and i asked him like
his bad he's like yeah it's not
it's really bad damn they can't get
oxygen i mean that's like that's the
thing
that they were saying if we don't shut
down there's just going to be
lines of family members trying to get
oxygen for their
and then you get you bring an oxygen
tank to your [ __ ] loved one like
cool well that's the funny man i gotta
eat
i let me eat in a restaurant
um put [ __ ] open her up
that's the thing like we thought okay
well if they open up it's gonna end up
that bad but now i didn't even
anticipate that oh we're just gonna have
examples
around the world of the worst case
scenario
and no one no one's touching the story
like conservative sites because it's
like
worst case scenario of what could have
happened or what can
right because so during the pandemic
when people are fighting like open it up
and i'm like
okay well if you die your people die are
you gonna be are you gonna be sad are
you gonna be like [ __ ] is it like maybe
i shouldn't have fought like
i think everybody almost secretly wanted
negative redemption to happen to people
like vengeance they want like florida's
fine meanwhile it's higher than
whatever right exactly so most kids
getting it
etc cetera yeah but then now we have a
terrible example which is india no one
wants to talk about it it's very sad
why india is gross like that's what
they'll that they're defensively like
this is india
england germany canada
then we're talking then americans are
like well they look like me
well wait a minute australia like
by the way by the way yeah go ahead
you hit that song please apologize
oh man all right i want to
talk to you um no i'm sorry
everybody in australia that wrote me i a
guy was like i'm
mid email i'm so mad at you
i'm like bianca really said some
disparaging things about australia last
week
which i was blindsided by because i
didn't
think anyone could have a negative
opinion about australia like
what's to what's not to like well we're
not you know i didn't touch the racism
we're not going there
it's not worse than american racism no
but
what do you think right but what country
doesn't have it's like every country has
some aborigines whether they call them
that or not
uh-huh so um i
that was bianca shouting out her black
female listener friends going like
i need to defend you put up a fortress
it just was like it's not a country has
races
it's just the the previous conversation
that things um
i and i told some of the people that dma
i was listen you guys have gross icky
monsters there that i don't want to be
around i don't like spiders
i don't like school about aborigines go
ahead neil
sorry i i that's my take on them silly
um so that has really tarnished my view
of australia because it looks beautiful
and all the coasts look lovely you know
um but there are disgusting spiders
hiding under every rock and shoe and
pillowcase
i'm very scared of that's like thinking
that everyone in it
if you go to la like you go outside
you're gonna see
arnold schwarzenegger no but every
australian friend of mine
confirms it there's there's spiders
everywhere there's flies everywhere that
i cannot confirm or do not
there's you know about the the
kangaroos fighting in neighborhoods so
every time
this is from my australian friends they
laugh at americans like
yeah there's not kangaroos jumping down
the street americans are
idiots what do they think they're
getting but they are but there are
there's
viral videos of them then neil tagged me
um
but do you know i don't know like what
the [ __ ] they tell me there's no
kangaroos jumping down the street
your friends are lying dude they don't
want you to go to go to australia
is that what's going on they don't
consider it i don't like panamanians
there's monsters everywhere australian
guys kangaroos i don't know where you
guys got that from we don't even have
them so
it's mostly the scary [ __ ] uh and
i'm sorry for offending my australians
but you can understand
i watch a lot of nature shows and a lot
of nature talks every poisonous thing
is from australia the most poisonous
snake they're not
in melbourne though on the high street
you don't know that i do know i do you
don't
i do there's no poisonous
rats on in oh right no i'm just talking
about spiders
yes spiders i can't speak to spiders can
be anywhere but the
real bad ones are not in melbourne or
sydney
they are actually doing a show at the uh
sydney opera house just spiders anyways
it's all spiders orchestra conductor
audience all spiders and i'm sorry
because the human seeds aren't big
enough for how [ __ ] big these
spiders are i'm sorry i projected my
insect phobia on your whole country and
i'm sorry
[Music]
i like [ __ ] now you have two now you
have two sorrows it's so funny
also i got you should apologize because
a woman said that if i'd slipped her a
note at whole foods
she would have liked it okay my defense
is this i was on
uh maybe it was an elliptical or a
treadmill at the gym and i had my
headphones
on and i was doing my thing
and a guy came up and he just put his
phone in
in front of me and it was a note saying
that he found me attractive and put my
number there and i was
i wanted to die i felt trapped
i met the [ __ ] off i'm at the gym like
and i said
i stopped exercising i'm like oh no i'm
sorry
and then i thought that was so invasive
and weird
so but if you if he's cute people say it
in your wedding toast
so no for sure and i've always said that
i've always said it creepy if you're
attracted creepy's romantic yes
and if you're not attracted to them it's
creepy but that guy was good looking
and i still was like guys i wouldn't i
don't feel good at the gym
yeah i wouldn't do that to a woman ever
too late do you hear me you would never
ladies are you listening
um i would never disrupt you maybe
getting in better shape for me
do you hear how i ruined it in my
romance i made it about sexism but
what if that girl would only take that
phone
that kneel note from neil because she's
attracted to neil
and maybe that's take it from where you
said it as like
it felt to me like you said it like
absolutely never do that
any guys should never do that because it
feels like i don't have a choice to get
out of this
you know yeah she put a fake number in
she got she
she showed me won't happen again ma'ams
mayhems will not be doing that again um
all right now the service workage
servers
service worker shortage um
i don't know if i buy it or not
i don't i think everyone's making a
really big deal out of this to be like
see yeah gave them too much money yeah
it's like it wasn't that much money
first of all yeah it's like it wasn't
enough to 1400 is that the money the
1400 bucks
yeah the 1400 the 600 and the 12. i'm
like
uh over over 13 months
the [ __ ] are you talking about it's not
like [ __ ] you boss
i just got 2 100 bucks suck my
dick forever on all platforms that's
like those
that i don't know that similar scenario
where
they look and they the lotto number is
wrong
you know they quit yeah uh i don't think
anyone's doing
the problem is okay so the pandemic
money right but also
the unemployment the federal
unemployment
mm-hmm which has been six hundred
dollars a week at the beginning which
was
really especially yeah and then it went
to
then it stopped for a while and then it
went to 300
a week um
so people are saying that that 300 a
week along with your unemployment
depending on states depending on which
state you're in
has made people like not want to go back
to work because it's enough money but
i don't i don't think obviously it's
probably it's a republican talking point
to say we if we do this then
they won't work lindsey graham most
recently brought it up but
ladies i don't i don't know man i i
this this hurts my biases
meaning i don't want to think that
people are
i think people want to work like i think
people want to work
they want a job that they aren't
humiliated by
that's where the problem comes in well
yeah it's humiliated and they're
the minimum wage in some states that
they can't they we can't find work it's
like
you're paying them two dollars an hour
yeah i mean not literally but yeah
like it's two so those are states in
china
no no no there's um there's certain jobs
that if you
divide like they'll pay you like oh it's
300 for that but if you divide it's like
yeah you're not giving people livable
wage yeah
uh but you want them to come back and
flip burgers
for a job that's they're unappreciated
that's a poor person's job
that's i think part of it is
if do that and get covered
is is a big part of that i believe
and then i've also seen articles where
people just don't want to be
don't want to wait tables again like
there's just [ __ ] people don't want to
do
and they'll do it it's there's an old
jay leno joke about
um his wife said
that the cat was being finicky with
food and leno goes up lock him in the
closet for a week let's see how finicky
it is
so so in that regard
it's not going to last forever no it's
not but i i
it's just weird how all the right wing
talking points come out saying like
oh if we pay if we raise the prices will
go up
and labor like job job the unemployment
didn't
didn't go down enough there they only
had a 200 000
which if i'm the president i'm like it's
a [ __ ] lot of jobs
um that's where it's an impossible job
like [ __ ] you 200 000.
you [ __ ] yeah uh yeah so it
just feels
like let's [ __ ] on workers doing
a very under under-appreciated i don't
think it's about that i think it's about
uh political football that they can use
against
democrats for giving out too much money
i think that foreign and it didn't it
now well now they'll never come back
right but the rhetoric ends up going
obviously from
politics down to like regular people
being like no one's to work
yeah it's like people actually want to
work yeah i just i
i'm still the mind that people want to
work do you know anything about this ppp
loan thing
yeah a lot of this a lot of black
instagram is talking about people going
to jail
forgetting a lot of people some people
just applied for it and
just bought expensive
there's only like two famous situations
a guy
got a ppp loan for his business and then
bought like a [ __ ] like a lamborghini
or like a rolex or something
well he sounds great it wasn't it was dj
khaled
uh no apparently i mean like a lot of
philly apparently there's a lot of
people getting arrested oh you're people
well yeah yo people um
yes i grew up in philadelphia with
not exactly philadelphia uh the thing is
if you
i know people i grew up by the tennis
courts
the language you understand they were
like by the tennis courts
um i there's a lot of fraud like i think
so many people frauded that california
edd the unemployment
something like i don't know i think it's
like
39 million dollars in just fraudulent
claims that's actually not that bad to
me if it's only 39 million i'm like man
it's hard
we got that or maybe 135 i don't know i
don't remember but
they're all gonna everyone's gonna find
out they don't have time
these podcast is where facts come to die
yep they're gonna come we don't know
them
we don't know the facts we know what we
think we might have heard well i know i
read a thing that said
the biggest fraud in california history
has happened
during um unemployment like during the
pandemic
because so many people applied for it
and they didn't have the manpower to
give to interview you
so they gave everybody they approved
everybody for unemployment without
discretion
yeah well this is this goes to the thing
i was saying uh
the same i bet there's a guy or woman
out there who
frauded the government out of loans and
returned a dog
after after bought a dog
with a loan right then was like [ __ ] it
i'm returning it give me a rebate give
me my refund for this dog i didn't want
this dog
uh that people are this is why we just
have to constantly be looking at you
monitoring each other like hot which i
don't like but
apparently we're not that moral the
longer i do this podcast more uh
elon musk elon
um hosts aren't live i didn't see a
frame of it
but i remember last week or two weeks
ago i said i called him an asperger's
case
you guys laughed like i was being me
and it was a bridge too far and then he
said
and then someone even tried to write
some on twitter about it and then he
said
i have asperger's yeah which is you can
tell when someone had that's my point
you can tell when someone says thank you
um well crushing it
yeah um so
yeah you can tell when people have
asperger's you know we'll have uh
uh borderline personality disorder you
can tell when people are bipolar
you can't always tell maybe you can tell
borderline
borderline i can't tell by looking at
them borderline i can tell by
you autism but yeah borderline is like
oh i'm an [ __ ] and
do you worship the ground i walk on
depending on your borderline
is is uh san francisco weather
we're like yeah what yeah you were just
we were just [ __ ] and 30 seconds
later
you're accusing me of taking money from
your atm account
that's that's borderline borderline is
weird yeah
you [ __ ] that you cannot it's so
the accusations are so wild
it seems like you're lying because
you're trying to even understand what
they're accusing you of
yeah i was i got home from work
i dated someone who has borderline he
doesn't know he does but
he does and he's not listening
and i got him from work from the store
and i'm like
i smell like alcohol we've all seen it's
not pretty good
and i was like okay i'm going to go take
a look i turn the other way when i see
you at the store after
after 11 when i want no part of this
so i remember i came home to his
i was like oh okay i'm gonna take a
shower first before like we hang out or
like eat or what he was like wow really
a shower
like yeah what's the problem
it's just weird strange
did you think i just got like a [ __ ]
done to me i'm like i just came from a
place i smell like red wine
and he was like i've just never heard of
someone doing that
i love [ __ ] like that i just never in
all my day you've never heard of someone
taking a shower when they get home
okay ever and you can't convince them
that they no
that's a fake and [ __ ] crazy thing to
say it's the end you know then this is
the most enduring
energy is okay no no no no no
no i want you to take a shower now if
you want to take one
away it's like you've lost before you
came stepped foot in the house i was
already gonna lose it didn't matter
there's no winning there's no winning
it's weird it's you know sorry
if someone's going through or diagnosed
with borderline i'm not trying to say
your word
but you're weird but it's really weird
for the person dating you
and you're like do you why am i but they
don't remember it
is a weird thing oh i had an ex
who so keith
occasionally would do incredible
things where he would eat stuff that he
would just
get out and get into food that was like
one time he got out of a cave
out of a kennel cage and i came in the
garage and he's standing at the top of
the steps and i just looked and i go
how'd you do it so
he would eat stuff he wasn't supposed to
eat and then
and my ex at the time was like i think
he just does stuff and like doesn't
remember it
and i was like no he remembers because
he knows i'm mad and he knows why i'm
mad
right and she was talking about herself
yeah
oh wait she's projecting herself
literally like oh i've
done this i've not eaten stuff but i've
done [ __ ] up [ __ ] like
like gone through your phone yeah and
like but i don't remember it
which is why that one particular ex when
we have talked very rosy recollection of
the
relationship i'm like you're a bullet i
dodged you you're
you're baggage you're what people get
baggage from i didn't date you that long
cause it was fine but
you know i follow an instagram account
called narcissist narcissistic
sociopath abuse um and it's great
that's amazing just constant things
about like it was them
it was not you the only thing you do is
eject
there's a woman who just does narcissism
youtube videos now wait and would like
she's a narcissist or
well she what's funny is she's become a
narcissist over time
no i think my personal narcissism is
something that can just be you can fall
into or do you think true narcissism is
because it's hard to be it's hard not to
be narcissistic if you're getting a lot
of
attention that's selfish i know it's
selfish but do you think there's a way
to
mimic i think there is
but i i don't have proof you've been
around people that aren't
probably cl true narcissists i've been
around narcissists i've been around
people that got a lot of attention and
it made their narcissism worse i've
been around people who just got a lot of
attention and just make them selfish
it's a it's also a chicken egg thing
yeah like
as greg fitzsimmons says only the true
narcissist
succeeds in show business uh and i think
he's right
um like who yeah it's like what came
first
um but is that a count for narcissists
or is it for the people that dated them
or
are in their lives meaning
is the content geared towards like
it's no it's not for narcissists because
narcissism i've said on here
they have the disease you get all the
side effects
it's like it's a really good one now
good one neil
well we're good i'm waiting we're
waiting for this good one
yes uh
there's no they also die no one ever
recovers from it
no one wants to recover from it but
narcissism is also
awful for the narcissist in their head
they're not living a great life um i
don't
think that it's not like high fives do
you know what i mean
i don't think that's ever communicated
to them
it never gets to them because they've
got so many narcissistic layers in front
of them
right the message never gets to them but
okay so the one narcissist i've dated
was infinitely harder on himself i think
deep in an
in an internal way that wasn't always
outward but him not
achieving some like grandiose level
whatever
he took so hard in a very strange way
like it was like
you know yeah it's almost like it's like
they'll like bang their heads against
walls [ __ ] like that like hit themselves
with shoes
[ __ ] like that as well it wasn't that
crazy but it was
it's as if he was crying because he
didn't become president like weird stuff
i'm like
why would you have achieved that you
didn't do anything towards
but then they then they cheat on you
with some hot girl and they're like
they're like that you know and they're
like
i'm back right they get very they
i've learned on the website they when
you deprive them of their narcissistic
supply
they they don't they can't function
they get they just find it somewhere
else they just literally
find like go to like no matter the
quality
yeah just go to the club anyone warm
body
yeah warm body that'll spend time with
me so in that way you're right that it
is
would be a hell to a healthy person yeah
they don't know any better yeah
that's good and if they're talented they
can find those people
if they're talented in the world and
they're popular famous they can just
there's
a never-ending supply of narcissistic
supply
no it's just to fly oh
so you know the kentucky derby horse
brianna is on drugs
it was gatorade uh it was
thank you very much nyquist um
how was that uh briana taylor related
medina spirits
oh then she's not the maybe they have
other they
they have under cards or maybe they have
a lot of other cards
yes i think it yeah no the race the main
one was brianna
no that's the main one the main one is
the is the one that goes oh then who's
brianna
horton brianna won for thursday
oh yeah race four that's on thursday
[ __ ] out of here
so great um
yeah so the so the
but the here's somebody said it's called
the horse
at junkie which is very funny you know
who said it
donald trump that's a [ __ ] funny guy
how did you get that message he's not on
facebook uh
i believe he released the statement i
swear to god
no he i swear to god uh
junkie dude didn't even write bizarre
statement he released a bizarre
statement please
actually all of his statements when he
released his statement he goes
hey we should release a bizarre
statement they're all busy
uh deep thoughts on the winner that's so
why does he have deep thoughts on the
winner
yeah what is that is it junkie it's that
what's happening to our country
the whole world is laughing at us we go
to hell on our borders our fake
presidential election and everywhere
oh my god he's what are you talking
about that's
the whole world's dying of covid dog the
whole world's not laughing at us
uh or it's certainly not about you know
their america
you mean where the horses are on drugs
all of the horses that run competitively
are on drugs everyone in
every single athlete in the world is on
drugs calm down
in some way shape or form they're all
anti-inflammatory just [ __ ] that's legal
even
when the guy said the owner goes like
he so the horse tested positive for such
and such and then he's like
which if you know and it's he had such
ease with the term
they're just constantly like put this in
geesh put this in just constant
i'm on [ __ ] some [ __ ] right now
you're on some [ __ ] so
i you know what do we know if that's
like an
actual interesting drug it's just one
that doesn't make you
cool and talkative
um corticosteroid which they give yeah
it's
it's for when you have uh yeah
allergies suppress inflammation uh yeah
so it was probably in test positive for
claritin
yeah yeah they're all injured they're
not supposed to do this
of course they're not so they're not
supposed to be built it's just all of
it's wrong so it's just a matter of like
we're gonna prosecute this one wrong
that we all just said
okay it reminds me of an old tweet
i just watched the kentucky derby and
the winner as usual
was white people um
syndicate it well well
syndicated you're getting there
the guy [ __ ] it with the vocal by by
pre-lapping the vocal
under the second piano note but you'll
deal with that um
here's something this is a new segment
called hear something
cat the great cat keane who um
is a producer of the show now apparently
um she pointed out
that we have so many heavy topics
we should lighten up sometimes i feel
like this week's been pretty light
because
there were no black people getting shot
or arrested for no reason
um and so
how about a little like show and tell a
little like did you see this
no it's just so cat wants us to take a
break from racism yes
easy for you cat yes
um cat thank you um
so this is called this segment's called
did you see this
which is what jay leno used to say
underneath
setups of jokes did you see this yeah
you see this
will do you have an audio of that um
that's the name of this segment that's
literally don't change anything
may get slightly better at it but we'd
like goofs are gold
anybody seen the story um anybody see
this right
jay lena you love him
let me say something about jay leno very
quickly okay
jay leno called a comedian
friend of mine who was doing a late
night show
and he said you know what i like about
when you do your jokes
even if you don't like a joke you'll
stare down the barrel of the camera
you know i don't know how you feel about
the joke he goes when so-and-so doesn't
like a joke he looks up and to the right
when so-and-so doesn't like a joke he
looks down and to the left
he knew everyone's tell that's funny
like that's the level when people were
like that guy's not funny i'm like
that guy's so [ __ ] advanced comically
you can't even
you don't even know what the [ __ ] you're
talking about yeah
anybody's hearing the story um can
anybody see this right
uh what's up during the pandy
pandy the price changes well if you'll
go on axios
okay so these are things i could have
done a quiz [ __ ]
all right we'll do a question i didn't
look oh okay good all right so these
things
well just go first one all right so you
thought no
no will i want to do a quiz where i
asked bianca
what happened to what anybody seen the
story ooh this is like
price is right when you have to see yes
you saw the first one
uh laundry given went up how much
percent
during the pandemic things went up a
certain amount because there was such
demand for it
how much did laundry equipment tell the
people 2.9
29 jk 20 i guess i didn't see the dollar
uh
you got asperger's congratulations
car and truck rental oh
a rental
20. 24
major appliances uh you have to be
within three
plus or minus um uh 27
19 [ __ ] i was gonna okay did you buy any
of this [ __ ]
no i rented a i owned an rv
you did not rent it it was a long story
for an ayahuasca thing you wouldn't
understand
um okay uh and major appliances
when i bought a bunch of knives
and major appliances
no um but people did yeah
i just thought it was more because
people did a lot of baking yeah and
that's all right
um okay i did buy a pan
serla tobb was going out of business so
i dropped by did you get the
our place pan was that the copper one
no i just bought this [ __ ] pan and i
don't
love it what's the deal it's like a
hipster [ __ ] pan that
is everywhere and my friend's head i'm
like drives a fixie
it's that cool is it that cool a pan
it's it drives a [ __ ] fixie and
when i got it it's like armband drives a
fixie
as soon as i got it the instructions
were like don't do don't make it too hot
don't put in the oven don't don't don't
make it don't pan don't do pan [ __ ] with
it
i was like okay uh next one is a little
weird
propane kerosene and firewood
went up how much percent 15.
nailed it 100 i'm gonna suck a dick from
the back
that's what happens go will
pork chops what person did pork chops go
up um
i'm gonna go with nine ooh eleven nine
eleven never forget
she
and trucks used cars and trucks not a
rental
purchases of used cars it couldn't be
that much
couldn't be 12. 10.
you're really getting you're really
doing something
really good with your mouth okay
now what now things some things went
down okay okay i was thinking
women's dresses went down how much
percent 30.
14. [ __ ] what's wrong with these [ __ ]
suck my dick from right
i'll suck your dick from the back public
transportation
oh i guess they lowered prices i didn't
know they could lower prices but
oh yeah there's there's no price on the
buses here
because really the driver hey what it's
a it's a
it's a gofundme no it's because the
driver doesn't
because the driver doesn't want you to
walk by them
oh that's interesting so you go i bet
you know what's funny is i bet they
didn't want you to before
now they're like fine they have seat
belts you just can't in the front
yeah um public transportation probably
down
18 15. that's
three that's it yeah it's three so i'll
sell your dick thank you
men's suits oh 30. let me go back to 30.
17. i'm confused who's buying
tell me about it telephone hardware
now i don't know if that's cell phone or
landline i'm assuming it's
got to be because i can't imagine
landlines didn't go down a hundred
percent
um i'm gonna say gosh
12 20. [ __ ]
airline fares went down how much percent
21.
25 just out of the window just out of
this suck my dick window
damn it um so did you see this do you
see this
what is it what's that what's the name
of this one
um that was good that's interesting suck
my
um wild wild uh
i i'm surprised at some of these
yeah men's suits what men's
yeah women's dresses maybe you know what
though on sale stuff
so it didn't go down that much women
knew they'd be wearing dresses soon
they knew they played the long game um
yeah i don't uh i don't know what to
make of it i'm
always find it fascinating you know what
i bought at the beginning of the
pandemic that
cost me more weights
physical weights for my [ __ ] body
yeah
um somebody came at me about my body and
i just wrote like lady i promise you i'm
in better shape than you
um the
weights i bought them used because i am
i play tennis but i don't play tennis
you know what i mean you see why um
and the weights
i was like have these they doubled in
like
three months the beginning of the
pandemic weights literally just heavy
[ __ ]
doubled in value heavy [ __ ] with handles
double
milk skyrocketed no but yeah it was
that's the thing i bought that i was
like
[ __ ] yeah i went to do that and they
only had 10 pound ones which was fine
mm-hmm and i paid you'll get there
you'll work up to it yeah go ahead
and uh i'm glad there were
nothing there was nothing available
because i would have bought a lot and
then
i really only needed 10. no i just
realized i don't like working at my
house
interesting it's i don't i don't go hard
i get tired and i'm like this is stupid
i love it
because i love doing my skivvies like
bikram
i put on a speedo and get to work like
bikram
i harass women like bikram does they
think
um uh two b's bikram
um i'm reminded of a david tell joke
from the 90s
which was i went to the gym and they had
two pound weights
and my first thought was oh yeah they do
whoever's lifting that how did you get
into the gym
how did you open the door to get into
the gym wait how did that what does
david tell
that he did that joke oh that was him
yeah yeah in the 90s
uh do you want me to tell you do you
mind yes you're
yeah is he the story uh so
there's like a girl made a tick tock
because ben affleck she she matched with
ben affleck on raya
and then i don't know she got freaked
out unmatched
and then ben affleck sent her a video
being like hey darlene
why'd you match me and then that was it
on instagram founders literally can't
even watch the i watched that one by
accident
and i found it so wrong it was so [ __ ] i
do not look like it's so mean
yeah i don't want to watch this oh i
kind of do
oh this is i can't no no i hate it i
hated somebody
he turned different it feels so [ __ ]
up we all have dirty laundry but
if i took your dirty underwear and put
it on instagram we're all going to be
like ew
yeah this is by the way it was never
offended celebrities
when i maybe shouldn't have it's [ __ ]
like this
where people just nice they just use
them
as a it's like the amount of people i
it's i dicaprio was gay just all the
[ __ ] i've been hearing for so long
and and then friends have it's just
i i it's wait so you're where are you i
don't know where you are
it happened in matt perry too it's so
mean
it's just [ __ ] wrong like it's such a
violence you match with them
so what's the problem so your age limit
is 55.
so his age limits his age limit's 18.
right which is what who's why is what he
did wrong
and what you did fine why would you put
him on blast
and and you know where it leads to i
think
why and this has to i don't think that
it's
all the women posting about it and [ __ ]
is uh uh your friend called him out why
though i don't get it
oh chris he did oh bad i know i i hate
her
um the
it's just wrong it's so it's like wrong
for you to put them on blast
and if you want to change the legal age
for women
change it otherwise or change the laws
where a 50 year old can't try to [ __ ] a
19 year old
because what you're saying is
women are being taken advantage
of by a guy if he's above a certain age
it's literally they can't they're
powerless
meanwhile madonna's dating a
20-something year old she's 60.
yeah and that's empowerment meanwhile
gay dudes the age disparity in gay dudes
like
[ __ ] wild like everything else um
no one can women aren't mad about that
if your 45 year old friend is like i'm
[ __ ] a 20 year old
yes queen it's because
you women think that every woman's being
taken advantage of
in some way which is like are they or
are i thought they
i thought we're all equal is it are they
using their fame and power
right no for sure i
i i'm actually fully with you but like
women are being taken advantage in a lot
of ways this is not one of them
yeah i don't know women are not paid as
well as the [ __ ] like that and
sexual assault nonsense i just don't
this is to me it just it's
it's cruel it made me feel very bad it's
like uh
it's doxing them basically it's doxing
them also
you wouldn't want it to happen to you
let's just say if you were
it was put on your i don't know towns
bulletin board whatever
your version of being doxxed for the
and i don't know again if they get
married
it's adorable no that's as awful if they
get married
now that she docks them but if he said
why'd you unfollow me and like he really
showed passion and he really
cared about me follow me over a
different app like we met on one of them
i will say if he if someone unmatches
you don't find them
and ask them why not good i mean
it's you've never been horny as a man
he doesn't need to do that yeah but he's
pretty good you go i need god this girl
and whatever
right you want to you want that specific
person these are weird
look um so it's wrong
and i think it makes when when adult
women go like this is wrong it's like
what's the [ __ ] law change the law
chrissy should go to [ __ ]
the governor and or the senator
or the mayor or if you really are that
offended by it go to the
go go and then go get madonna while
you're rounding up fools
right i just it's and then go get
scores of gay guys 55 year old gay guys
who are [ __ ] 22 year old gay guys
i just think as a celebrity you're
always on guard
to not just be in this position
and i don't know it just it felt like
it's like so easy i mean
well darya's there's a ton of women on
riot that are famous that
i wouldn't be like guys right look who
it is the [ __ ] out of here again it's
always just men generally do not snitch
like that because we will have to
women are very good at not snitching too
but all the snitches of the last couple
years have been women engaged
well because they don't define anybody
anybody seen the story that was anybody
seen this story
anybody see this wow if
all our whole podcast was as funny as
making a segment called let me see the
story and keeping the audio
i we really you'd be honest we'd really
be i wouldn't we wouldn't be doing this
podcast let me put it to you like this
um critical race theory not worth
talking about too serious
take the note
this week huh let's give it a rest huh
um
critical race theory and we want to get
into it um
but there was some fox mania about
critical race theory
it's weird to what do you want people to
talk
i don't get it i'm like if something's
racist let's just call races
right they're making critical race
theories
that is like a neil brennan [ __ ]
sting operation which someone's having a
range of confidence
i'm like wait what sir you're wrong and
here's why
you want to seduce me yes literally
critical reasons yeah you want to watch
a documentary about race
oh i'm already hard um i didn't think i
could get any harder
um it basically says that everything
critical race theory
says that racism informs every single
thing
in america in its history and today
and i'm
prone to agree with it yeah
to a degree but i also think they're not
going to sit there and be like
everyone's evil you know there's a ways
to teach it
so people understand our history the
problem is we have such a white washing
of our history and like glazing over
like these were hunters and gatherers
like we skip a lot of the massacre
to like natives we skipped you don't
they don't school is not long enough
12 years couldn't you couldn't cover it
in 12 years
if we just learned that we'd still would
not still i'd still be in fourth grade
this this age this size this size
size size uh
so i just it also is in the saw it's
just
bad writing in the south no we can't
teach it
you can't say anything you cannot blame
anything
on bigoted history
so it's like yeah it's still it's uh
over
it's it's an overcorrection on both
sides um
we're going to have a very boring
segment called over correction police
where we just go that's an over
correction we don't explain our
congratulations
um so that's critical race theory we
solved it and
um let's go to doc watch
[Music]
pretty great thank you really wanted to
see lucy but i've already seen a thing
on her
on the chimp but i just was it good
yes okay um
it was good animal people are weird
i mean uh any animal trainers have dealt
with
very weird um did i ever tell you the
story about we had a
we had a monkey on chappelle show in an
episode where dave was just like i just
feel like it'd be funny if i just walked
around with a monkey
another
cut the beat just [ __ ] chop it yeah
here's another day's spell story which
is uh he used to say you would cut me
out of the show if you could
because i love [ __ ] chop it [ __ ] down
not the podcast that goes 2 30. come on
now but
um so we had a monkey
yeah and we did try to just do a remote
with him just walking around with a
monkey
and it just didn't work it was like it
just wasn't
you kind of gotta do [ __ ] you have to
like go to the gun it's like why on
reality shows like
we're going a hot air balloon and it's
just so you
have a thing to cut to and whatever and
there's like
the beginning the middle and the end of
the hot air balloon um
the monkey passed out at one point why
well for some reason he was wearing a
do-rag
and a chain at this point and i
can't remember why it's so funny it
sounds very funny sounds very funny it
just didn't work
okay um and the [ __ ] beastie boys
gave us brass monkey for 10 grand
that's a big deal but absolute steal
they never licensed it to anybody right
absolute is steal a way to splice it so
that it's funny
not real it just wasn't not enough
happened i don't know
it was the interesting thing though my
therapist saw me
while we were shooting it which is so
[ __ ] funny
is me dave and a monkey and camera's
walking around
monkey passes out i believe the monkey's
name was ungayo
and guyo yeah so the monkey passed out
and the trainer kept kind of like
ungaiu starts giving the monkey
mouth to mouth and when i tell you
it was very hard for me and dave
and some of the costumed women to not
laugh our [ __ ] ass is off
giving mouth-to-mouth to a monkey
wearing a d-rag and a chain
it was very funny now there's a sketch
yes it was very fun
so it was the that lady was weird the
so loose the documentary is interesting
uh uh like the way she said it like in
guy and literally like
little slapped him on the monkey shake
so and he's wearing a dragon chain
um i remember dave did a joke
uh every time i come around your tree
bling-bling
when he had the monkey that might have
been the best joke in the whole piece
anyhow animal people are weird
and it's the ladies kind of weird
and so it's interesting sociological
just watch this kind of weird lady
recount a time in her life where she
lived on an
island with 10 monkeys by herself
for six years it's hard not to be weird
people are weird enough yeah pandemic
yes agreed it's like yeah i don't know
exactly what you're talking about but
um yeah like so
that's interesting did you ever watch
that it's like
actually like a it's a giannis it's in
the giannis collection but it was the
one
like when coco the monkey was
smaller it was like in the 90s
and 90s there's like that one scene
where she's with three
chimps and they're all or gorillas and
they're all in the car
they're both all three of them have
their seat belts on they're just like
perfect
it's mama's name and everybody name it
name it it's all weird it's kind of
weird to be yeah you i think you have to
be it like you were saying
to be good at a sketch show you have to
be a maniac yeah to be good at we were
talking before the show we said we do
talk
when you when you do a sketch to do a
good sketch comedy show
you have to be a maniac right and yeah
that's the longs i mean because i was
like well what if you're a good enough
this and what if you're good at this
you've got to have a maniac
or four maniacs in every sketch yeah
um so to be uh these like
animal people these like lifelong
animal people you gotta be a little
they're just a different
vibration where yeah at one point it's
just interest like at one
one point the
she had to like convert lucy to
monkey food because they were she lived
with people and then
she got them from the people and
whatever she had converted monkey food
and she was like
at the end of her rope and like
screaming and sobbing
and passes out and then when she woke up
lucy was eating the monkey food like all
right [ __ ] fine i didn't know you're
gonna [ __ ] pass out
um so there's moments like that there's
a thing where she said like at night
weird [ __ ] would happen like what like
god [ __ ]
like what like ayahuasca god [ __ ] shut
up
um there were like i don't want to
i don't know if it was leopards were on
the island but there were
animals that could have killed her never
touched her or the monkeys
just cool like she's like i was
protected
yeah there's uh my friend used to i
guess he lived on a farm and they had a
bunch of animals
but they only had one pig i don't know
why they weren't gonna kill it whatever
none of the animals would eat they would
all feed them at the same time and none
of them
would eat until the pig was done eating
yeah like that where you're like man
that's [ __ ] unbelievable what's
happening here
so he was like where the roosters were
will circle another dead rooster and
you're like
guys i don't know what's happening i'm
gonna give you guys
15. and then i'll come back this seems
like turkey [ __ ]
and that's got nothing to do with me and
then have fun and we'll see it
right happiness it's your business yeah
this is between you and the turkey
um so it's worth watching and then
there's another one on hbo max called
generation hustle
i was gonna start it but it looked a
little cheesy there's like
eight of them yeah which right there i'm
like what these aren't they can't be
good
over four and you're like what are you
guys doing right and it's just about
scam artists yeah but the problem is
they're all like young the yes they're a
little sexier
but the problem is in the they
in my experience the first episodes
they're like
yeah they're titties like huh this is
you like this
you're gonna get more of this this is
that's their hottest [ __ ]
when that yeah someone was like yo
and then they explained it to me and i
was like sounds like metabolife
just like well yeah a lot of well yeah
you can't treat an honest man they all
want to get
they all want to make money quickly so
but it's
more like they didn't get the person
doing the scam they didn't get the good
internet they didn't get the person you
need
or they didn't have enough footage of
the person you know what's a good one
it's it seems like a new
flashier version of american greed and
american agreed is so good
i'm like why would i watch this is that
the one keith that guy keith is the
voiceover guy american american greed
yes keith what's his name from uh from a
deadline or from
no he's not that's not he's a different
guy uh different voice
no kevin harris no it's uh i know it's
he's the one that um
uh what's his face would do his um
impressions
so good who's done again no no
he did it's not american state oh it's
stacey cage
interesting it wasn't the other american
greed yeah he's very
yeah no uh uh wha
who's the comic that god i feel bad
um very good at impressions the best
impression jeff jeff
so jeff did the dateline
dudes have you ever seen him do the
dateline dudes bit um he's like
and it was that handkerchief like
yeah that's that's funny it's so good uh
yeah
uh how do you know this guy you're like
he was um
a big actor in the 80s you know when
there's like a big actor like
you know if you're like tom selleck
you're like yeah why are you famous
there's those like cbs guys right that
are not appealing
they're not like sexy [ __ ] the
hottest guy you've ever seen
right right they're they're more like
masculine and relatable
um and stacy keach was just on a bunch
of [ __ ] in the 80s that was
big yeah caribe jesus of nazareth
blue and the gray i'm like never the
gray was a big
mike hammer that was mike hammer 84 to
87.
the new my camera yeah he was all he did
the old mike hammer the new mic what is
my camera
some private eye [ __ ] color just
everything was private
i mean look the face of the equalizer is
a private eye
i mean about the negotiator the
negotiator
not private but um and generating so
generation hustle not good enough
sorry generation [ __ ] you were not
good enough let's do some emails will
[Music]
wow
[Music]
hey neil binks will uh active listener
here
ma and uh podcast i actually just moved
to the la area and i just got my hair
cut for the first time
like pause it real quick he's already
got la energy
yeah he's just moved to l.a just
actually just moved to the la area
yeah and uh doing a show if you want to
come
here's a flyer hey we should follow each
other team fallback
go ahead sorry i'm just [ __ ] on this
guy who's nice and i went to a local
neighborhood barber shop that turned out
to be a black barber shop
yeah large high quality pictures on the
wall of like historical black hairstyles
sure and everything was going great for
like the first 20 minutes to get me in
the chair the guy's super nice he and i
are talking about fishing and he
actually like invites me to go fishing
with him like in a couple weeks
but then he reveals that he believes
that melinda just broke up with bill
gates
because she discovered that they're
putting nanobots in the coveted vaccine
or something
and i didn't know what to say to that
and so i didn't push back on it
because i didn't want him to like make
me look like a clown
in the barber chair but i also realized
that's something i feel very strongly
about
not being true and would absolutely like
push back on and call my friends out on
or like somebody i knew
regardless i know where he's going you
can pop we can answer this right now
but what he's asking is what do you do
about black men's penchant for
conspiracy theories as a friend what do
you do
right and or
as a guy in a barbershop surrounded by
black dudes
you he was smart not to say anything
you have to have a wider breath as a
white person
with i every black i know has some crazy
oj bully
just some crazy i mean half not half the
sketches but that
that we did that uh sketch
the where dave's on jury selection for
all the trials
yeah because it was just like this
that's another stage
this is [ __ ] crazy i would i
eventually you'll come to argue with
them about it
but it's going to take a year yeah
comfort
and also understanding where how they
why wouldn't black eyes believe
conspiracy
or just distrust everything that goes on
in this country
but that's what it comes down to it's
like yeah just distrust
so if you look at it like that one you
can just
also but i also believe in i believe in
i
i don't know how he would go about it
but i think you can especially in a
barber shop you can
have a discussion there's no better
place to have
you have discussions so you could be
like you really believe that like you
really like what makes you i don't know
he's a white the only white guy in a
black barbershop
that's not the time to start go fishing
with him go fishing
that's when you go yo what the [ __ ]
um yeah but you're
you just have to the amount of
pretty much every black guy i know
believes something
that if a white guy believed it i'd be
like you're [ __ ]
out of your mind you're absolute the oj
the number of oj conspiracies i've heard
uh i mean tuskegee happened
um the nanobot like just they did
5g like did [ __ ] where you're just like
okay
i don't so if a white person said
something like that to you
i'd scream at them
and you know me i really would um
uh the
yeah so but yeah the amount of i
i the that co one of them said
one of them meaning a incredibly famous
black dude said
cove it'll be over after as soon as the
election november
5th if a white person did that i would
stick their face in the toilet
you being violent is so it's the best um
i i spent i put the money down into the
weights i'm getting i'm getting this
money back one way or the other
um so anyhow
so good question and welcome to l.a
kid goodbye see you at the sea at the
auditions kid
may the best man win you've got mail uh
hello nick and bianca
this is the bipolar guy who called in
once before
uh thanks so much for being so nice
about all that
bipolar stuff lstner
uh the reason i'm calling i am very
envious of
uh neil's spirit i think he's got he's
bipolar and we're just gonna have to
take a
we're gonna have to take it or he's like
a narc
he's like with the fbi like yeah hey
nicki minaj
is this where the cool people are willie
the producer
of uh neil's spirit padre status
and uh his feeling that there is most
certainly some
sort of an afterlife beyond what we see
um as a bipolar person i am told that i
cannot take
ayahuasca so uh what
would you say to somebody like myself
who is interested in trying to to
achieve a higher
uh conscious understanding of the
universe
but cannot partake in ayahuasca or
am i just [ __ ] out of luck thanks a lot
um can he if you have bipolar
if you're diagnosed with bipolar
disorder can you take
other uh psychedelics
i mean i think you can i think
it's what what did i mean i know i i
you can take mushrooms like i again i
don't take my word for it
no for sure but what did we read when
before we were going to do ayahuasca
that
why what was the reason because i know
you were paying attention because
there's a very
obvious one for ssris which is if you
don't
if you're on ssris and you take
ayahuasca your brain releases so much
serotonin
that you do something can happen called
serotonin syndrome okay
where you kind of overdose in serotonin
oh my god
uh it happens it's happened like once
but there is a risk
but there is a risk and i don't the
serotonin syndrome
what is the so it releases all the
serotonin and then what happens it's
just
you're like i think you're paralyzed
look it up wait what um
serotonin syndrome can occur when you
increase the dose of certain medications
um symptoms are agitation restlessness
confusion rapid heart rate
dilated pupils loss of muscle
coordination or twitching muscles
muscle rigidity heavy sweating diarrhea
headaches shivering
goosebumps that sounds funny goosebumps
uh severe serotonin syndrome can be
life-threatening
high fever seizures irregular heartbeat
unconsciousness okay
so not worth it even if it's a small
risk
um yeah so not worth it
the why bipolar people can't take it
i'm not quite clear on you don't know
really i
know because i don't know
i i don't know i think maybe
you're likely to have a psychotic break
oh switch to mania
after i was a conception yeah you're
gonna go
you're gonna have a maybe a manic
episode that never ends
um oh my god that never ends i don't
know
that's what it sounds like switch to
mania if you just switch
i'm switching to manny i'm writing so
many sketches
there's something i'm wanting to tell
you i'm switching to mania will
why won't you click on it click on what
we can do you won't click on it because
there are articles
yeah but the background we can get a
prey c
crazy god look it up we're going to look
proceed up after this it's a real word
you want to break there's an increasing
use of ayahuasca for recreational
purposes furthermore there's growing
evidence
for the antidepressant properties of its
components however there are no reports
on the effects of this suspend
substance in the psychiatric setting
harmaline one of the main components of
ayahuasca is selective and reversible
mao
inhibitor and serotonin reuptake
inhibitor conclusion
they don't have it they don't got a
conclusion why and it says that he like
had a manic episode after ayahuasca
and so yeah so don't
don't do it hypomanic episode in the
past and it's currently depressed
well
um yeah so i don't know why you can't
and what would i do
if i was bipolar
to get to
hypotropic breathing which again i don't
know
look it up uh
holotropic breathing sorry you can
basically hyperventilate your way
into some something
something something we'll we're gonna
let the bipolar friend
do it and he'll let us know what happens
uh sir we need you to do it before
next monday when we record please
if you record it and then send will cut
it down
um the so you just hyperventilate
into an altered state i've done it
before i did it for like 15 minutes one
time
and it was my arms got like is it
fuzzy and it's like huffing paint
it's i don't know i don't know i look
man
i i here's what i know i know that
people are willing to endure
any level a lot a very high level of
risk for
to get out of this level of
consciousness drugs
as i've stated on here before the first
45 minutes of every drug is
are you dying am i dying are you dying
do you feel like you're dying i feel
like maybe i'm dying are you dying dying
dying and then you don't
and then you get through that and you're
like oh that's [ __ ] awesome
we're gonna get more so if you breathe
lying on your bed and breathing i don't
i don't think it'll kill you look it up
holotropic breathing
uh have you done like breath work
like holotropic breathing but breath
work classes maybe not necessarily that
um no i almost took a holotropic
breathing
zoom zoom yeah but
i mean are you talking about b-sides
re-learning how to breathe like i did
this week yeah i did
and i wish you would listen to me more
because it's the first thing i started
the podcast with
you don't even listen anymore get my
friends swear by
this breath work class where it's just a
lot of like deep
fast breathing that's holotropic
breathing
they don't call it that so yeah that's
it's yeah that's what it is though
um there you go right there
shut up will no one ask no will you were
right humiliate bianca
i'm humiliated um so
good good one good good letter
uh i don't i mean maybe try holographic
breathing and
also you could also switch to mania
that seems to be a pretty good if that's
an option
goodbye you've got mail hey neil and
bianca
thursday watch here before i get into my
question
neil i saw your set in bangkok two
decembers ago
and i think it's about time you start
planning return as the city is in
desperate need of your fine brand of
comedy
um kind words and persuasive flattery
aside though
last week you mentioned your
misperception of athletes age
and i gotta say i feel the same i hung
up my rugby boots
in my early 30s yet when i watch games i
still somehow
see these 20 old kids as my peers and
have the ridiculous thought that i still
have something left in the tank
but that ego driven age denial quickly
passes when i pinch one of my messed up
shoulders and attempt to lift the cup at
a weird angle
neil from one aging man to another
do you have an anecdote of a moment when
your mind was telling you yes
but your body was telling you no and you
had to admit to yourself that you were
aging
bianca you seem a little too sprightly
for this question to be relevant but i'm
sure you've witnessed guys attempting
things their bodies are definitely no
longer equipped for
side note as a south african i really
appreciate the love you guys show for
trevor
cheers and keep up the lack of podcast
i'm good with my ex good one good one
yeah good one thanks
you'll never have a song play a good one
is that from our podcast uh was there a
moment where my body said
my something said yes of course i was i
was in bed with this 18 year old
right i'm facetiming with this 18 year
old i realize she's recording
um i'm trying to think of i
broke my foot
two weeks ago what no you didn't what he
when you if you break your little toe
there's nothing nothing you can do
and then you're and i broke it in in a
in joshua tree just oh the airbnb had a
table
that was like three different little
tables yeah so it had
nine legs so anytime you wanted i
jammed my toe twice broke it like
literally happened i got uh it's broken
like immediately because it was so
[ __ ] painful
and the bruising's been wild it's been a
while it's been a while
that seems like an aging thing i used to
not break my feet
and there's nothing
not not nothing comes up that i'm like i
used to be able to do that
and now the good news about me is i
never did anything
so when you get old you can't go i used
to do this and i
can't do it anymore i never did anything
so i used to read
[ __ ] and watch documentaries and now i
can still do that
i guess i chose wise i chose old man
behaviors
yeah i was went to a trampoline park
with an older guy
um that's a tough that's a that's got it
that's a
that's uh
he made a mistake he [ __ ] up yeah
uh one two good rounds on the
on the tramps and lower back was just
he was just like i gotta sit like that
oh
and it didn't what made it worse like
insult to injury was there the
like the volume of little kids running
around yeah
there's like clearly stay away from me
no
that's you there's one thing you can
never show a woman
lack of coordination never have i i'm
sure i've shared this theory never let a
woman
pick you up you know what a woman's like
i can pick you up
i literally like i've said to women you
don't want to do this
there is no coming back from this i have
picked ian
up so many edwards and every time he's
like stop it no
i told you i don't want you to do this
i'm like get on my back
yeah and and it's so funny but i have a
very strong back
i picked up joe i picked up brogan did
it on my back
huh lift them off the ground is picking
up he was in a vaccine
clinic right and you walked in and
picked him up threw him on your back and
got him out of there no
i didn't i can't really lift him i just
was like no no he's like
don't do this i'm like yeah i don't know
i can do and it was like
and you're never gonna have sex with
abram
you don't know that i don't know that
ian edwards has the finest
quiet sex game of anyone i know he's
smokey
rogan's a smokestack you don't know that
he's married i don't know well yeah but
you know it didn't make them like ew
yeah i hear you oh not to you but what i
would say is
be careful what you do
in terms of physical coordination around
a woman so
like you mean stumbling or you don't
want to stumble
you're if
if you fall she's not [ __ ] you for
minimal
four hours hilarious yeah if you fall
and make a noise
it's a week if you go like
she's not [ __ ] you for a week but you
get out of bed and make a noise
right guy already just [ __ ] him he
said what are they gonna do i don't know
i can't at this age i can't [ __ ] again
for a week anyhow so
who again i beat you i i win again
goodbye great well thank you for finally
getting the message about these audio
and video messages we've been asking for
two [ __ ] years
that people make audio and video
messages because it just makes the whole
thing better it's so nice i'd much
rather listen
yes you've got mail
hey neil and bianca long time listener
from new york
uh comment on last week's show
neil you said you only really approach
women who give you that available sexual
energy and i
feel that to my core um
don't want to be a creep when somebody's
going to the supermarket or laundry
you know you don't want to be that that
guy um
to bianca's point during the same
conversation
where she said that she shoots her shot
i feel like it's admirable
and uh i think there's a big population
that
big population of people where if you
never do that
if you never put yourself out there
you're only going to be approached by
people who would do that um
which maybe i'm not going to throw a
percentage out because i have no [ __ ]
idea
but there's a lot of people out there
that aren't confident enough to shoot
to shoot their shot with you so if
you're not willing to kind of meet them
halfway or give that available sexual
energy
aren't you eliminating a big portion
of your potential mates anyway
that's all i have to say love you guys i
it takes me a while to grow i need to
grow into that he doesn't love you yet
um there actually is a question about
loving people in this
in the written in the room um
uh yeah he's right you're cutting
yourself off and i know so many girls
where i'm like
girl this isn't the bridgerton
right like just
people are so afraid of rejection but if
you just process it in a different way
it doesn't have to be
you rejected me my square f
every square footage it's like no no
it's not about that it's just
you will end up literally how you are
now you'll either be here or
better yeah and i only say that because
there are girls that you know they want
boyfriends they want a relationship
but we have these olden day rules in our
head
that it doesn't count if i you know
put in more effort than him or it
doesn't count if i'm the one who'd made
it happen
i don't know what i don't i don't know
how to help
uh yeah i
i think women i personally would
appreciate if women hit on me more
really
uh yeah because easier but it's that's
what i like about apps
is like i'm interested in you are you
interested in me
yes and if if she's not i don't remember
liking her in the first place
yeah i think absolutely better than keep
uh
[ __ ] filings and videos this loser
affleck i'm getting
completely honest uh that's also why i
think text messaging
apps and text messaging are better for
guys yeah way better
way better because because you can't
directly go to women at the store and
offer them a fill in the blank because
it's wrong
because it happened to be uncle once so
no man should ever do that
goodbye hi michael neil and aunt b
love your podcast what a great team
neil's my favorite comedian ever since i
saw three mics and
i'm a tuesday woq that's without
qualifications
listener here's the question neil
what is your writing process like for
developing material we know there's a
lot of work that goes into your clever
jokes material i would love hearing how
you develop your ideas
as if you don't have enough to do
already can you try to show us
how to take an idea and make it funny
perhaps with this concept as a starter
quote a mixed marriage has previously
been when people of different
different racial racial or religious
backgrounds married
a present day mixed marriage is the
relationship between an android
and an apple user a swing and a miss
kitchen
will [ __ ] killed it no one's gonna
come around here with a premise again
not for what will just did to him that's
this
that's the mix the the mixed marriage
thing
is a fine set up android apple
is a 10 year yeah joke so that's kind of
the way people
understand comedy they understand it way
late
right so now a mixed marriage would be
like like a gender so yeah
yeah or like vaccine or
or like flip flop like you know what i
mean like something
a tiny house thing not literally a tiny
house thing but like
it does need to be topical like you can
be a good dj but if all you're playing
is 20
like 25 songs then you're my kind of dj
then you're my favorite teacher enough
in the club you just have to it has to
be
super current it can be the same formula
but you have to the mixed marriage is
not a bad
thing it's a tag basically it's like
it's a mixed marriage
um but but the the mistake is the apple
android so i'm not going to show you any
process stuff other than wow
apple android secrets i'm this is also a
trap where i try to
now you and people like it was unfunny
[ __ ] all over me but meanwhile i would
have never even tried that
it's like this i got an abs noted thing
on here where i put them all in there
and then we go through them
what used to be once a week before covid
and now i don't know when i'll do it
next because i have a bunch of material
all i feel like ian has that like that
ian about the android user joke
ian edwards joke about it yeah it's so
good
apple android there were a few a lot of
people did the poor angle
yeah the ian basically makes it that uh
if you want to know what it's like to be
a black person like
have an android it's like oh yeah yeah
yeah it's very funny it's like
everything comes up green you're like
you everyone else is blue and you're
like green
um i like how we've blown two ian
edwards jokes
i know i'm like cool you know if you're
not listening goodbye
bianca big fan of the show don't worry
about what day i listened to it
neil finish spell show love 3 mikes and
thank you for introducing bianca to the
world bianca you seem like an awesome
person
it's not my style to write an email but
i spent a lot of my adult life in
minnesota and i think i can add some
insight and clear something up
that you keep getting wrong about the
shelvin trial yes
uh i'm sorry you and an email in the
last episode are confusing two different
women who were witnesses for the
prosecution
one is the 9-1-1 dispatcher has happens
to be a bi-racial woman black and white
or as it's known now apple android um
who got the call and sent chauvin and
his boys to cup foods cup
is right it's a knockoff of cub foods
uh when she saw chauvin had uh george
floyd pinned to the ground for so long
she thought
the traffic camera she was watching was
frozen realized it wasn't
sent an emt and also called chauvin's
sergeant to say something was wrong
this is where she said she doesn't want
to seem like a snitch the second woman
is a firefighter happens to be white
um who was off duty but walked upon the
scene of the murder
she tried to offer cpr and get choban
off of george floyd but was stopped by
the other officers here's my insight
which you may be interested in
i used to work with the 911 operator and
she's a really good kind person
her deal is that she comes from a cop
family her dad's a cop
uncles etc she actually wanted to be a
cop but her family
wouldn't let her because she's female so
when she called chauvin's sergeant and
she said quote
and she said wasn't trying to be a
snitch she knew how to talk to a cop
and how it would be heard um and i
assume the prosecution used her as their
first witness because she is
in a she is in a way a police official
the defense couldn't say was anti-cop so
uh
say what you want about the thin blue
line both women were trying to keep
george floyd alive
just want to let you guys know you're
confusing two different people trial was
hard to watch when i get it
uh this is good information i didn't
know that
yeah actually i also didn't know she had
the 911 dispatch has access to
like a cc yeah that's a funny thing she
thought it was frozen
i mean it's like let me read them hey is
this
frozen no no we just haven't moved um
the this is a good
uh that ev
it's about bias it's like her she's a
cop family she's this
is everyone's bi it's like you're you
had a bias
because a guy held a thing up at the gym
so you're like i don't think that's a
good thing for any guy to do ever
we but we all walk around with i have 70
of those
that's like well i have this now
my bias is ah right
and almost every fight
every argument is someone's bias and
then you find out later what their bias
is you're like
oh if i knew that then i
wouldn't have did it right now but it's
usually like i got triggered by a thing
that reminded me of a thing that you had
nothing you
had no way of knowing um
so somebody there's actually
a letter about that later some really
good letters today sometimes
it'd be a real [ __ ] you've got mail how
do you feel rcnle how do you feel about
the idea that cops don't prevent crime
they just take criminals to jail that do
um and uberx and uberx
khan if you will xcom
the major threats to society are murder
rape and
thief and best case scenario there take
someone to jail
or give you a police report to bring to
your insurance company in which case
the pen and keys truly are mightier than
the sword
i think he's saying cops don't
stop crime they just come after it
happened and clean up
you can't the problem is you can't prove
deterrence
you can't prove people don't
graffiti in high visibility places
because
if the cops drive by you're [ __ ] like
the [ __ ] like that
you don't punch whatever there's a lot
of them that you don't do
because either cop will drive by or
whatever so so cops we need them
just don't kill people don't kill people
that's the point you they
they maybe they did it's hard it's like
religion how much deterrence are they
doing
goodbye bianca neil
i heard you talking about feelings and
how some people can manipulate you with
them
i would like to share with you one way
to avoid this i came across this process
called non-violent communication
developed by a psychologist named
marshall rosenberg
a jewish psychologist now i've seen
everything
it has worked wonders on my
relationships the first time i've
explained to me i thought i will finally
get to win some arguments with my wife
anyway if someone tells you quote i feel
you have to do this or i feel abandoned
by you
first realize that these are not
feelings don't tell them this just
notice it
and then try to guess what is the real
feeling behind their statement
uh i.e do they feel sad hurt angry
confused etc and then try to figure out
what need is not being satisfied that
makes them feel the way they feel
maybe it's a need for collaboration or
affection or
another one um uh i hooked you up with a
list of feelings and needs
but thanks thanks thank you this way you
acknowledge
they have uh feelings and you also
acknowledge
what is important for them changing the
conversation from guilt or shame
to being there for them without being
manipulated hope you guys read the book
nonviolent communication
a language of life it's interesting and
i think it's a good
uh base for efficient conversations also
if you're ever in tijuana let me know
and i can recommend some good tacos and
nice mexican food oh my goodness do you
want a lot actually
all right you want to know where there's
good maxine food [ __ ] everywhere
it's tijuana now um
uh yeah i tried to listen james and
jamila recommended non-violent
communication
and i tried to listen to it and the book
on tape
the voiceover was so bad no i
could not like what [ __ ] bullet i
don't i can't even categorize it
the art of speculating he wishes i wish
that kid
if only i'm gonna pay that kid to
re-record it um
so so i hear about nylon
violent communication i think
non-violent
sounds i think it's probably not
uh accusatory [ __ ] like that
what i've realized i feel like
most
most of the time when a woman has a
problem with a man
i believe it can be mostly categorized
as
i don't think you like me as much as i
like you
i think that's the bottom line you
relate whatever the thing is
the the underlying thing is i don't
think you like me
either as much as i like you or very
much or
whatever because i think there's another
problem that women have which is they
don't ever think about
do i like this guy they just think he
likes me
[ __ ] it and then that becomes the whole
thing of gauging how much they
he likes you in that moment a whole
other argument i have an issue where i
there's guys that i realize i'm like you
don't
i don't mean like like me i'm saying
uh take [ __ ] out of it if you can
no reduce it there's some times and i
think it goes for both sexes where
they like the idea of you more than
they actually [ __ ] with your personality
that probably happens you a lot
no that sounds rude but i just mean that
it's like oh
neil and he's funny but it's like you
know how
i make the jokes right right so i'm just
sitting around
it's not like it's not like okay
yeah and you're i i just think
people have ideas of each other yeah and
they'll still rock with you but you're
not exactly
hoping a few more boats
that doesn't happen to me very much
because i don't i don't read
as once they get there they know or
you know i don't read as like i'ma buy
you a chain i take tennessee i'm not
going to publish a court
you don't ice them out uh i don't know
it said two year anniversary um
the so i think yeah i think that
that thinking i think most
problems are most guys excuses are
i don't want to spend time with you and
they have a million reasons why
no yeah that's true date you i don't
want to spend time
and i think people would be well served
by getting better at like
not a match it's just not a match
like eh it doesn't work uh this is not
like
it's not better when you're around it's
funny i gotta argue with friends because
i said
i was explaining how i ended up not
talking
anymore with this guy and they get on my
case saying i should have told him
exactly why
i didn't like him like no that no
life coach therapist normal person would
say
i have to give all my energy to somebody
that i'm choosing
not to get into something with and tell
them exactly why i'm like why why would
i do that
they're like it's my one friend said oh
well
i would like to know and i think it's
like a courtesy to know like i don't you
know no one wants to just
sometimes you're left wondering ah man
like i thought that would have worked
out
and it's weird that it didn't but i said
also
that's not my responsibility or my
problem to inform you
because the choices we make to get into
a relationship are very different than
the choices we make to get out of one if
we were in a relationship
i think i can be really straight up with
you and hey these are the things that
aren't working but
if i'm not going there with you i don't
owe you anything
it's also mean it's
because i don't because it's not they're
my they're your particular issues
exactly particular things that didn't
work for me
i so i think they want you to tell him
and then he'll [ __ ] do a montage and
change and it's like
nobody's changing nobody's changing [ __ ]
why would i go because i said one of
them is that he drank more than i
cared for and they're like why didn't
you tell him that i'm like well he
didn't
maybe he didn't drink a vlog he's not an
alcoholic a lot of people go out
four nights a week and drink three or
four drinks yeah that's way too much for
me
not for most of america yeah why would i
make him think he has a problem when
it's just
my prediction it's selfish i was
really kind of annoying i'm like guys
also
nothing also i mean also let one guy do
it to them
right see how well they i don't like the
way your toes grow
or something and see how helpful and
constructive they find
it when they then they go under the
[ __ ] knife
like i can do it no i got the ideas
i just wouldn't do it because
it's not helpful right thank you yeah
goodbye you've got a devoted tuesday
feeler here
i really do love everything about your
podcast and i thank you both for the
time you spent each week
i have a chapelle show question we'll
play the song cause it's too long and i
can read over it
i know is not this podcast
uh but i'm taking a shot uh the sketch
where tron pleaded the fifth
how does that even happen do you realize
at the time when you're writing will be
referenced 15 years later
uh goat no i don't like the word goat i
think it's
i know you didn't read it on purpose
and it's not also not it's nothing it's
just a thing nail's the greatest of all
time
is that the greatest sketch of all time
um
the sketch came about it's a sketch
where we switch
the white justice system for the black
justice system
and it came about because my sister who
i will not name
was mad that ken lay from
enron got perp walked
and alan iverson got to just turn
himself in
at his own discretion
uh as a white woman she didn't like that
she thought it was
um and and i pointed out that it's the
first time it's ever working that way
and then we ended up doing it that's
really funny yeah and
and then we added like the law order
ding ding right between it
the ding ding is yeah
yeah yeah burr is very funny in that
sketch
the judge is very funny in that sketch
and who else is in that sketch
the the guy the white
the white guy is funny he was like a
perfect
just [ __ ] like what the whole time
and dave is so [ __ ] funny it's
that's not even the funniest thing he
says in that skits the funniest thing he
says in that sketch
is um the finest meats and cheeses
he pluralized meats and cheeses which is
[ __ ] hilarious uh the
and then the fifth thing is it was
written that way
but and then it just becomes a thing of
like
i gotta do something on each one
so it's also a thing that he's
incredibly maybe the
when i say like
like in my decathlon where it's like it
was him and eddie
and then at a certain point
dave overtook eddie in my head beca it's
not like eddie can't do that [ __ ] but
it's like
that thing is like he'd [ __ ] do it
almost every day
right where it was like right wow
i mean not every day but once a week
like a lot
and which didn't say that eddie hasn't
done it or can't do it
he's never really put himself in the
position to have to do it right
um but even like dave's scene
with eddie and another professor he
improvised right
no every line he said he improvised
david
who's sucking whose titties over he told
me he said it
that day that's so he's like i was like
improv
and jada and i and i came out i did like
the raw pose
right and i said who was sucking whose
titties tonight
or right here and it was like oh okay
like okay
i don't i don't know what the [ __ ]
you're talking about and then you see
like oh
okay so funny yeah um
so that's what we're talking about where
if you're going to do a sketch show
maniac mania switch to maniac
switch switch to maniac you one of
we were he's an
absolute maniac and i'm a maniac
in a different way as he said we were
like thrill killers
where i'd be like
he'd stab somebody and be like stab him
in the [ __ ]
face davey like just [ __ ] crazy
crazy people encouraging each other so
thank you for the question it's a but
it's a pleasure to bring up that's
happened
goodbye dear mail steer banks and
brennan
i was watching a show the other day and
they had one of those scenes where one
person says i love you first and then
doesn't get it reciprocated and of
course it's then all heard about it why
are americans so obsessed with
saying i love you and being a romantic
love but not
with being loving human beings on the
planet
romantic love is so elusive uh but being
loving
towards others uh can happen today right
now with tangible immediate effects
so tell me what is this obsessing with
chasing the abstract i love you moment
how could it be counteracted with
something better for humanity
should it be i like this question
this is uh hong kong jimmy's sister
who's now escaping me
she it was on the letter well
i have a few ideas about why saying i
love you is more popular
way easier than doing it right
it's like saying it's it's a hashtag
it's a hashtag or marching right it's
about that's about the proportion
and um
there's also something when you say i
love you
it opens up a lot of options
you get a higher level of merchandise
and treatment
that you would not get by having a
boundary right
if you go like really nice to meet you
man they're like
i said i look if i said i love you
then we're like it's a big la thing
where people say sometimes people say i
love you in l.a you're like what the
[ __ ]
right like don't no you don't love me
yeah it's like when your boss says your
family
that's the best i don't need it i'm good
i'm good i'm feeling big
ten kids already a problem
no more family for me thank you uh well
but you're my son
um so
um your thoughts on i love you
i think it's i don't know it depends
because i've been in situations where
i don't like an overused i love you i
stop believing it
very quickly like well that's another
thing
that happens in relationships where they
just feel like i love you it's like
shut up keep it down i love you or like
you're mad like i love you
yeah ugh we're not dealing with anything
you're
this is crin you know it i'm embarrassed
that you think this is working in the
way that you think it is it's not at all
uh so i don't always
love i love you i i
i i love it no i'm but no it's a it's a
cheat
it's a cheap but i feel like you don't
go around saying i love you to people so
if you said you loved someone i feel
like
there's weight there's value to that
yeah well
that's yeah and then there's two they're
like yeah i have like
categories my buddy my friend like i got
a whole
thing a guy i know well buddy
you guys don't like it but buddy is
right below friend
right above guy i know guy where's my
guy
my guy doesn't make the list my guy i
saved for
nba all-star weekend we're just going my
god
this you all know my guy um
a bunch of fake hellos that's another
thing you have to get used to black guys
a lot of big hellos
a lot of big theatrical hellos
yeah performative hellos um
thanks spinks and brennan i was watching
a show the other day
no no guys i [ __ ] up i [ __ ] up
something edited
out i love you guys lmnop
all right that's a yeah great podcast
great
stand up and great hair binky i'm a 30
you're i'm a 30 year old black guy
living in the northeast a few years ago
i was with a white woman
three years younger than me for about
two and a half years wasn't serious
we'd go out for drinks then have sex
hang out with friends then have sex
watch netflix
then have sex um good luck with the
three mics
good luck watch three mics and try to
[ __ ] after that doesn't even work for me
too sad
you get the picture after three years of
this cycle she calls to let me know
she wants to end things i don't fight it
someone doesn't want me
if someone doesn't want to be with me
anymore i'm not going to force them my
question
is in regards to women's dating strategy
particularly white women
this is generalizing but we do small
box blanket statements on the show well
we'll
[Music]
there we go smokebox blankets so racist
but do white women who date
interracially tend to settle down with
white men
once they hit their late 20s early 30s
or quote
the i want a husband face is it just
easier to start a family with what they
know
do they not want to deal with possible
drama from friends family and society
are they afraid of children with unruly
hair as always we'd love to hear what
you and banks have to say regarding the
topic keep with the good work
will too well i have a question for him
because it almost seems like he ca he's
happy to keep it casual
never accelerated the relationship this
is a funny thing for you to
this is where you show your priorities
meaning
no no no i'm saying like women
black stuff it's like you're
you're siding with women here when you
could side with
him because he's black guy over a white
woman but then
but you're also a woman i don't have
blind loyalty to anyone no i know you
don't but i'm saying it's funny
when we find ourselves we go like a
hierarchy
well because my thing is i if he said
you know
everything was going great i met her
parents
and then she just bounced on me and
ended up with this white guy and ended
up married i'm like oh yeah word let's
explore it but it seemed so casual
and they're in their 20s and then she
was like man i don't want the casual
thing anymore
now it's like do white women just leave
us i think i see a pattern here
yeah so i'm i'm like can i defend white
women here a little bit like
now it's a race thing i think was it was
it a racing when you were
when you were for two and a half years
no she was just a girl you were hanging
out with now it's like was it a race
thing
when you made her put on confederate
woman outfit
um um what then and you dress like uh
detroit piston did that seem racial
um i think
i of course this happens
um meaning of course white women will
[ __ ] a black guy
quietly of course on the side everyone's
got their
quiet blacklight with white women black
women
i don't know i know like a jewish guy
that was like right it's like i'm gonna
have my fun and i'm gonna marry a jewish
girl because yeah
it's just because i don't want to fight
my mom yeah um
the yeah it happens
i don't know if he seems like
way more hurt than i bet he
i bet he thought yeah i bet then she
thought he was gonna
be or uh he thought it was gonna be
if he had pitched like why don't we make
this she'd probably be like whoa i
didn't
think he played it too cool because
honestly she probably am going out a
limb here
thought you were not super interested
never gonna it was never gonna be always
gonna be this
this is a pretty typical guy move though
of like it's such a difficult guy move
it's like
whoa i thought we had something
like tell me you [ __ ] didn't ever
take her out
although they did hang out with friends
right hung out with friends but he
even i mean his words was very casual
sex was the main bond
yeah so i mean there's a yeah then
what then well there's also like is that
a bond for marriage
well can you change your hook up into a
serious relationship if you just are
really physically attracted to somebody
is that as valuable
as compatibility of tv shows in bed and
habits
and all that [ __ ]
you know some people you just have a lot
of attraction for
right and just like wow i still want to
[ __ ] you how is this happening
um well that's the thing though he
doesn't you can maybe that's not the
best
bond that that's not the best connection
but
it can't be that sad i mean you there's
girls you've hooked up with that if it
doesn't work out it's like
sad because the sex isn't there anymore
it's a it was like a store that closed
yeah like that's how i see people wow
stores that are either open or closed
you're like that was mermaids
there goes goodbye mervin's
said thank you for that 30 off sale at
the end i don't know what that means
sexually but
we can do something we can figure it out
you can do the math on that one yourself
do you see the story guys um uh
yeah i don't i don't feel a ton of
sympathy i don't even think he feels
done at the sympathy for himself but
making it into like
it's just a thing that women have been
working for
two and a half years two and a half
years you know i hit it and quit it
thing
over two and a half [ __ ] years
stumped me yeah
it's not like you you you are in charge
of jet skis and st
thomas and she [ __ ] you for the
weekend you [ __ ]
idiot um anyhow but thanks for listening
thank you so
you don't have a case though no he has
no case and he knows just enjoy it
don't be sad that it happened be sad
that it happened
be glad that it happened goodbye
tuesday listener here still positively
reeling from the apology regarding louis
farrakhan last summer
thanks for that one uh that might have
been the guy who threatened to leave if
we didn't apologize yeah
although i thought maybe we did
apologize really well about that um
tuesday okay i got into it the other
night with a close buddy who's a
bonafide
left-leaning gun nut told me he thinks
some gun control in the country
uh is good his argument still stands no
one on the face of the earth
is gonna take away my guns which of
course he believes biden will do
for a context he's a white college
dropout and has been saying he was going
to the military for the last five years
with absolutely no
steps towards doing that whatsoever um
he told me guns are tools personally i
would like to end mass shootings which
apparently is a divisive take
his take was that everyone needs to get
a gun and learn how to use it
or else you're gonna die uh i'm very
much in neil's corner with the no one is
going to try to get me argument being a
liberal straight white male uh do i have
permission to stop
talking to this friend forever because
he has literally
started talking crazy to me one of my
best friends but i'm tired of having to
educate these people especially when he
tells me
that i'm the one that needs a gun and
then it's their problem if people are
murdered in the
in in broad daylight in a mass shooting
ooh you're you can't stop talking to him
unless
he's black and then you just gotta deal
with it that's the point of the pod you
guys
it's called the unless he's black
podcast um
yeah i know a girl who was [ __ ] a
black guy quietly and she couldn't leave
him for two and a half years
um uh yeah guns
all right here's a gun set i do want to
get into so
will will you break down homicide
i gotta do gun gun deaths
per year
okay uh
yeah fair enough okay so
basically all injuries
mortality firearm does 39 000
deaths a year okay two-thirds of that
suicide
so now we're down to uh
20 deaths a year
when you look at where it's happening
there's a washington post article about
it actually
it's of course racial the amount of
violence
by gun the amount of uh
uh gun violence in america
yeah 113
all right [ __ ] it the the sad thing is
it's very hard that's how you get around
the paywall it's
very hard yeah apparently you go into
incognito mode i didn't know that
i learned that watching the podcast um
yeah don't worry about it i'll sign it
just so um
the amount of white people to get shot
kind of walking around or even someone
they know
is really [ __ ] low like [ __ ] crazy
low that purport
uh the sheer number of white people that
get shot is lower than the sheer number
of black people get that get shot
and when you look at population that's
insane yeah
um so uh young black men
teens made up 37 that's so
of gun homicides like [ __ ]
a crazy amount of homicide particularly
by 20 times more than their white
counterparts yeah
it's [ __ ] insane so
don't carry gun unless you're a black
man yeah
like it's 20 times [ __ ] higher
um can you scroll down well
uh across all ages black men were nearly
14 times more likely to die in a fire on
homicide than white men
and eight times more likely to die for
uh
firearm homicide than the general
population
so you're it's eight times more deadly
and that's before the cops get there
do you know what i mean right and i'm
not i'm not like a black on black crime
guy it's like
the cops aren't gonna help but it's in
terms of
just look at these stats what look at
what the
part when you look at a stat keep
clicking because there's [ __ ] that comes
up you're like
wow right the reasons for but what is
the solution
because it's not it's all the
the guns that end up in the hood with no
serial numbers or you know whatever like
that's
the issue even though mass shootings
like that it's there's just so many
different gun issues going on here
yeah like most of the guns in this
country end up in i think the hood issue
is happening before guns get there no
but i'm just saying when we talk about
gun control yeah we only talk about it
when it
refers to mass shootings whereas the gun
issue
in poorer neighborhoods have has been
there uh i know what it is like the
solution would be that lock
thing where it will only unlock with
your
finger fingerprint which by the way is
like very simple technology
for 20 years uh it's on our phone yeah
and they they don't want it on
they the gun manufacturers don't want it
on on their [ __ ]
but there somebody has and i don't know
enough and i feel like you've probably
watched a documentary or read about it
someone's making a profit on guns ending
up
like you know un
registered guns ending up in i don't i
think
that they're there i don't think anyone
guns are leaving the factory
and going to the streets they're going
they
are legal and they're accounted for
for a while and then they just they
become
apparently in chicago they just they're
not allowed
in city so they just go to indiana and
get them
[ __ ] like that um and
i don't know about serial numbers and
ballistics and all that [ __ ]
the one the bigger issue is
uh slavery meaning
it's all just pretty direct
to slavery no that's i just wonder when
we talk about gun control in this
country we're not talking about these
stats
we're talking more about mass shootings
and
even though that's a whole different
thing and like kids have to
do drills that are very sad these stats
are like
the people the real problem the real
problem is not
yes that yes so
uh right but that's because then they go
it's mental health
if it's a mass shooting they get crazy
yeah um
the guy ran out two suites at the
[ __ ] hotel at the
at the um with the one the gold one
the mini bar yeah um
yeah that's that's how you know he's out
of his mind he actually ate the m
m's from the refrigerator um
yeah it's just a crazy amount
um of black people
getting shot and getting shot by
being shot by other black black men
goodbye um
black man getting shot by bachmann it's
a scourge
i'm gonna go so far say it's a scourge
hello bianca
i know rogan's a big deal on comedy but
i feel like everyone is giving him a
pass here
people aren't mad that he's expressing
an opinion or that he's doing a poor
man's version of daily show
infotainment people are mad because joe
is getting people killed
by all reports he has 11 million
subscribers if we conservatively say
that one percent of his followers
will follow his advice and covet as a
two percent fatality rate
that's still 2200 people even if we say
everything is in his favor and only one
percent of those people actually get
sick and die
that means joe killed 22 people just
like if he had convinced them to commit
suicide that makes joe rogan
the bill cosby of negligent homicide
no it sure doesn't i know we've gotten
used to conservatives in politics
handing out bad medical advice
but we aren't going to forgive them
either maybe you're not
um on an unrelated note much love to
binky
so this guy he's got a lot on his plate
right now
uh i don't believe that joe
is responsible for 22 people dying 2
200.
no he said uh 22 people will contract
and then 22
people will die because of because of
joe's bad advice
um again if you can this is that thing
of
where fox mania
yeah roganitis
um there's got to be funnier once then
there is
mania
there's like rg there's a good one like
yeah an urgent yeah um
answer like cancer oh get it
uh it doesn't work don't worry about it
doesn't work don't look too much far
into it
um answer the
[Music]
i i i
so this guy's saying because people are
gullible enough to listen to a comedian
that that comedian then has to um
not give his opinion about things
anymore
which is like no i don't think that's
how that works boss
like he's not now like after after how
many listeners
yeah does he have is it his
responsibility
to get nothing but facts because we have
a lot of listeners
we've been wrong about [ __ ] before yeah
i don't i'm not i don't feel like we're
responsible for it
no um and it's like it's just it's weird
because i get why people were upset with
rogan but
everyone has to take a step back and
realize
their emotions are misplaced
it's just they're misplaced i know even
though it feels like
nah but [ __ ] him because he said the
thing it's right he can say the thing
and you know when i say that anyone has
problem with joe fight him
fight him i did
and i hitting really hurt me very badly
i was in a coma for
nine months um yeah it's just
it's the the daily show he's trying to
this guy had a pretty confident uh
letter but you're not gonna get me with
it's not
uh to or answer the question at what
point
does he need to start uh just
reading uh bulletins from the government
right
he said if i he said a thing that he
would say to a healthy 21 year old
that was dumb and because
and then he said the next day it was
dumb
right so let's not put so much steak in
this right
he the cove is already gone
why don't you look at the fact that
people are getting
their you he's not he's so far
downstream
in terms of the problems yeah exactly
that it's not it's
silly look i i personally don't take
this [ __ ]
anymore i feel like you probably don't
either
[Music]
um
[Music]
is how do you feel